welcome to this video and I need you
smiley because one of my most fav most
frequent opponents is here GD from
France maybe I can do something else
something like this maybe I can take and
play civ 5 just something else I don't
think that this is particularly great
but why not try form some alternative
line may be here to play c4 it looks a
bit passive yeah but still I can also
maybe later I go for see 4526 then III I
don't know I really have no big
experience with the fianchetto system
not but this does not look too bad maybe
I can really simply play Knight 95 some
time now if I if I will see to see
protector how does it protect f7 e6 then
maybe III and 94 okay interesting
yeah I also want to go 94 oh this I
didn't consider at all looked strange to
me strategically speaking green before
Queen before this nights is six so
probably just retreat and I didn't
expect that at all because it removes
pressure from the center but ok he has
if I yeah that's definitely true so III
here why should I take we're taking
looks weird
Oh Bishop you three yeah maybe try that
ed for Bishop deform possibly Knight f3
bad bad back bank and now I've gotten
rid of the dark squared Bishop and this
shouldn't be too bad think about d 594
would be very nice to get in mm not sure
about this decision I get the night to
you for now very likely and unless is
playing this ok so I don't want to
exchange Queens particularly
I go Quincy three Queen deform isn't
this a good end game probably okay on
the other hand if I just take it play
III it's also a good end game actually
should be able to to get some pressure
on the pawns with this excellent Bishop
ing to reform young inform to make sure
that be five is not happening he has
Knight a5 possibly but but still
yeah get it over get it over to see
three possibly also Knight f6 check 95
attacking the weakness directly can be
done check 95 but ok let's just go go to
the square wed wants to go anyway ok um
Luke d1 probably look t1 the ideas rook
a2 b2 now the c-4 pawn remains isolated
and located by the knight on c3 he's got
this piece activity but I don't think it
ultimately will help him that there
might be tactics of course but just um
strategically speaking this is
problematic frame also look various rook
captures I in now at some the c-4 porn
has two jobs here protecting be three ND
three okay I cannot I cannot take now I
think because of because of the rooks
getting into the game directly I can
play Bishop h3 though provoke a five and
now let's see can I go Bishop everyone
simply to exchange it or isn't this good
it's not so easy i can i can keep the
position as is
at the moment there will always be a
pawn that I need to attend to when I
capture and then Luke c7 is coming so I
cannot cannot do that at the moment take
on be three rd three okay let's fix the
pawns and now see how to continue
[ __ ] at high morning maybe i can i
can approach with the king we have
behind on time as usual but not not
hopelessly behind i can go here yeah now
that's a piece Bishop g5 b3 also coming
it's a gesture with the bishop
controlling see two black resigns yeah
this was quickly quickly going downhill
yeah he just he just does not have a
good piece coordination here those
pieces are somewhat yeah they're
stranded f5 and just back yam it's very
difficult for black to play this
position the computer is on plus 2.5
already which is quite a lot yeah he has
a hard time to avoid the capture on be
30 d 3 in the long run after preparation
you went here Bishop defy this is also
strong already check and this okay I
overlooked this simply overlooked this
very strong of course okay age form and
here the computer already
gifts rook to e3 as a win yeah I wasn't
sure always this is because of this move
okay yeah I have Bishop f3 and route d3
to keep everything together okay i
understand i just wanted to prepare it
as thoroughly as possible and here here
just winning rookie three wins they are
win and then the pieces is one the
problem really is the structure here
when we go back this whole structure is
is now very favorable the computer
points out however Knight B 3 which is
good mmm interesting up he is getting
his getting in b5 that's a good move
technically and here he has this
tactical chance which is even leading to
a good game for black so probably this
wasn't the best way to go about it rook
be one first many also here after Queen
B 6 that's an interesting moment I had a
computer gives Quincy to as clearly
clearly superior they have better
development by far this is winning
already because I have to ship t5 at
some point I guess yeah my better
development will be important Here I am
I can just take because of seven Aang's
ok Quincy to where I didn't think about
that move much stronger than the capture
and here I must I must alter the move
order not this a formal but probably
something else look see one maybe b5
something along these lines now these
points a week should be something for
what ok thanks for watching